-Can you see me by the way?
Uh, yeah.
-Okay, good.
'Cause I just was wondering,
'cause I under--
Didn't you just
get Lasik surgery?
-I did.
How do you know that?
[ Laughter ]
-You got Lasik surgery,
which is a major surgery.
-It i--
Yeah, but, um...
[ Laughter ]
I did, but I don't --
I don't even tell people that.
-But you can see me perfect?
I just want to make sure, yeah.
-No, it was great.
I really can see very well.
-Do you take painkillers or
anything when you do that stuff?
[ Laughter ]
Well, I mean, do they give you
like laughing gas or something?
-They definitely give you
some pretty hard-core pills
after you...
-Yeah.
-...have a laser in your eye.
What is going on?
[ Laughter ]
-So you're saying --
So, post-surgery,
you're a little loopy?
You know?
You have things on your eyes?
And --
-What's happening right now?
[ Laughter ]
[ Drumroll ]
-Your mom may or may not have
videotaped you after surgery.
[ Audience "Oohs," applause ]
[ Laughter ]
And she gave us the video.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-For the television?
-Wait.
This is a world premiere.
You got to check this out.
[ Drumroll ]
[ Cheers ]
This is Taylor Swift,
post-surgery.
You were, like,
freaking out over a banana.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, here's Taylor at home
after her Lasik surgery.
Video taken by her mom.
Take a look at this.
This is real.
-Okay, so, she found --
she found a snack.
-That wasn't the one I wanted.
[ Laughter ]
-Stop, you can't cry.
That's not supposed to be
what you're doing.
-I tried to get this one.
-Okay, I'm gonna
get the other one for you.
Okay.
-I wanted this one,
but what do we do with this now?
-I'll eat it.
I'll eat it.
It's mine.
-But it doesn't have a head.
-Honey, it's fine.
I don't need a head.
-Okay. I'm crying.
I'm fine.
-Don't --
You don't want to cry.
That's not what you want to do.
-Sometimes it doesn't
go your way.
[ Laughter ]
-Don't fall asleep
eating a banana, okay?
-I'm not asleep.
My mind is alive.
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Don't be mad.
Don't be mad.
Don't be mad at me.
I made some calls.
-Oh, my God!
-I may have made some calls.
-That's on television.
-Me and your mom --
[ Laughter ]
You goes,
"This one doesn't have a head.
What are we gonna do with it?"
[ Laughter ]
Me and your mom stayed in touch.
-Wait.
She was kind enough
to drive me there
but cruel enough to film it
and give it to you?
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, that's what --
That's what a good mom does.
-Ugh!
-I love you, Mom!
That's what a good mom does.
-I was --
You notice the --
I had these goggles on,
which are really high fashion.
But then they had
to tape it to my head.
-Yeah, and you're
not allowed to cry.
And just -- Oh.
The whole thing was so funny.
-But I was crying, I think,
over a banana.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
-Oh, my God.
-Anyways, tell your mom
thanks again for that.
-Oh.
-She's the best.
-You know what?
I'm gonna tell her something.
[ Laughter ]
-Let's talk
"Saturday Night Live."
You're on "SNL."
You're great
on "Saturday Night Live."
And you're good at live.
Last time I saw you was
at the "Time 100" --
-I'm sorry. I can't think
about anything else.
[ Laughter ]
I had like --
-Dude, it's my favorite.
We watched it in the office
like 20 times today.
I'm like, "Oh, my God."
[ Laughter ]
"This is not real. I can't
believe we have this footage."
You're like, going like,
"But this is the wrong one.
I wanted the other one."
You're like, "What do we do
with this banana?"
And she's like,
"We'll take care of it."
You go,
"But this doesn't have a --"
-"But its head is gone!"
[ Laughter ]
-"It doesn't have a head."
Oh, my gosh.
It just was so cute.
It made me laugh.
-Well, okay.
So, I was at a party, like,
a couple months ago,
and I had like 2 1/2 mojitos.
And then the next day, drunk --
#DrunkTaylor was like
number-one trending on Twitter.
-Yeah, I saw that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Because, you know,
I go, like, from zero
to legitimately thinking I'm
a wizard within like two drinks.
[ Laughter ]
-"I'm a wizard." Yeah.
-Like, really thinking like --
-You were fun, though.
You were dancing around doing --
you're dancing --
-Yeah, but thinking about
the fact that that
went as far as it did, and then
we've got this happening...
[ Laughter ]
-This would be -- This is Lasik.
-...that you've done this now.
-This is Lasik lover.
#LasikLover.
[ Laughter ]
Um, "SNL" --
-I can't even be mad.
I'm just impressed
that you infiltrated my family.
[ Laughter ]
I don't even know
how you did that.
Nobody has my mom's number.
Like, how did --
-Yeah, I asked
for your mom's number.
But, yeah,
we've been friends for years.
-Oh, well, you know,
news to me.
This is great.
[ Laughter ]
-What -- What songs
are you doing on "SNL"?
Can you say?
Have you said?
-Yeah, I'm fine with saying.
-You can?
-I mean, I'll tell --
Well, you know, we gotta be
a little cryptic,
just 'cause it's fun.
But I'll probably do "Lover."
-Want to point at them?
Ooh.
-I'll do "Lover," but in a way
that I haven't performed it
before, which --
[ Cheers and applause ]
And then I'm gonna do a song
that I have never performed
before at all, live.
-Wow.
-So...
-That's a scoop!
I'll take that scoop.
Taylor Swift, everybody.